Here are this weeks top movies
-How many you got' so far? - You and me.
-Ha ha
Riding into theatres is the Magnificent Seven.
An action packed Western, about a band of gunmen
hired to defend a poor village.
-I seek righteousness. But I'll take revenge.
The family comedy Storks follows the adorable adventure
of two friends on a very special delivery.
-Just one last baby to deliver.
--Aaaa
-Can you do big things from such a small place?
In the inspiring Disney, drama Queen of Katwe
A Ugandan girl strives to become a world chess champion.
-She's winning!
Lets check out this week's Fanticipation.
So what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting!
See you next time on Weekend Ticket!